so our next speaker so want make sure I
get all the details right has a
13-year-old house plant that was given
to him by the mother of a man he wrote a
story about who got beaten up in the
street by his own lawyer so everyone
please welcome Gary my name is Gary hary
I am the investigations editor for
Bloomberg law um I uh I am not a
programmer I uh am a journalist and but
I I often I've worked in local newsrooms
and
I've joked many times that like I'm
usually the person who knows more about
data than anybody else in The Newsroom
um not so much now we have like great
actual data people but in a lot of
places I've it's been a situation where
in the land of the blind the oneeyed man
was King and I was the one i' Mann so um
what I'm going to walk you through a
little bit today is um how to request
data from the government how to get it
when you might need to sue them um which
which happens not not all that
infrequently um so a couple of things to
think about um before you file a request
the first thing you want to do is just
ask for the data um sometimes sometimes
uh it's online or governments Will Will
just kind of give it to you you don't
always have to go through the process of
a formal formally filling out a Freedom
of Information Act request and and
sending it along um but you know and
also it just sort of helps to have them
kind of know a little bit about what
you're what you're looking for um and
keep in mind that Foya is a particular
process it's a little bit technical
knowhow um a little bit public relations
persistence and a little bit like
practicing uh practicing law um so kind
of to to get us started here um many you
Pro probably understand this better than
me but just so we're on the same page
documents equal data um if if you find
you know a form online or something that
somebody has to fill out probably
there's a data set um that includes all
the answers to that form um keep in mind
that most often when dealing with
government agencies the first person is
going to talk to is probably going to
know less about data than you um it's a
public information officer that depends
federal agencies are better than state
agencies but a lot of times um you you
need to kind of remember that the first
person is probably gonna gonna need to
talk to somebody else um
so you know a a uh a grizzled reporter
friend of mine once uh once told me that
that you
know being requesting data and using
foyer requests is like practicing law
without a license and it really is and
the thing to think about when you're
filling out forms or when you're when
you're writing your requests and as you
go through the process is that to
document sort of everything as you go
because you never know when you may need
to um show that to other government
officials or put it before a judge and
you want you want to have clear
documentation of your interactions with
the
agency so what to ask for um I mentioned
already forms um anything online um
that's filled out through the database
somewhere records retention schedules
which can kind of act as a menu for the
data that um that that exists in in
various
agencies um contracts with third-party
vendors this is a thing I've kind of
come to realize over time that like a
lot of government agencies they contract
out part of their their data work to a
thirdparty vendor you may not know
exactly um What fields are in a database
from that but you can look online and
find out an awful lot about how they
keep their data
um just by by searching contracts and
even like this kind of the the the
advertising information from those from
those uh those
vendors um and then also obviously
schema or data dictionaries a lot of
times that's good to kind of request
even before you really know what you
want to request just to kind of get a
layout of the data and see what it is
because it's very hard sometimes for me
as a journalist I I I'm I know what I
want I want to know you know I don't
know coid data I want to know how many
people um got vaccines in a specific
area or something like that but I don't
know what Fields they keep and if I get
that I can figure that out pretty easy
um so moving moving on um and then know
the law that's involved um and there's
really kind of two parts to this um know
what foil laws apply so for instance you
know there's a federal foil law every
state has Foya laws some local
jurisdictions will have their own
peculiarities on how they deal with Foya
um so you really kind of want to look at
the law as it's constructed in the uh
the jurisdiction at which you're going
to be requesting information and so for
instance Virginia in particular um if
you look at just their basic law it
looks great it looks like you're going
to be able to get any data you want but
what Virginia has done over time is they
have um put in a lot of different
exemptions for different different types
of things um and a lot of them are what
I would call optional exemptions so they
could say okay I'm going to um I'm I'm
I'm I I as an agency can give you this
data or I might decide that you know in
this case it's not it's it's not proper
to give it it it puts it on the agency
to decide and when that happens often
what happens is that the agency decides
never to release the data and the reason
is often because they they make the
rationale that if they release it once
they have set a president and then
they're going to have to release it
again so dig into the to at least the
foil all part of it and look through
look through it see what exemptions
you're going to be running into and try
to maybe you know work with sometimes
you can get a lawyer to work with you or
people that are more experienced in
employer requests and and and kind of
see what you can work out to kind of at
least hedge that off even in your
initial request um the other part is to
read through the state code um or
federal covering your agency that's not
you don't have to read through every
piece of it every time but like a lot of
times you can find out um just specific
data that is kept just from that that is
required to be kept in state code so
that's another good a good way to kind
of both understand the agency that
you're that you're requesting info from
and then also what what they might
keep so writing a request this is where
the practicing law thing really uh
really applies you need to tailor your
request to the jurisdiction that you're
requesting information from again
through kind of looking at uh looking
through through the law and but you can
also often like keep the keep the
language simple um around the request it
depends upon what agency you're dealing
with in terms of exactly how elaborately
you want you want to go um but there's
there's resources out there for writing
requests for local and state agencies in
particular I would always go to the
student press Law Center letter letter
generator and what this does is it just
gives you a format and you say okay I'm
requesting information from Texas I want
you know you kind of write in what your
actual the information that you want is
and then it puts all the legal language
that that applies to that state based on
its foil request or foil all in there
for you um and them federal agencies uh
the national Freedom of Information uh
Coalition has a pretty good kind of
there's no real good generator anymore
there used to be a really great one but
I think it's since died but the foyil
wiki and um and the national Freedom of
Information Coalition have some pretty
great great tools to kind of help you
and then also federal agencies a lot of
times you can go to the website you may
have to fill out you know some basic
info but you can just there's like a
portal where you just kind of put your
request in they email you a response and
and it's it's sometimes much more simple
even than state state agencies
um so and this this uh this this thing
here this is this is from the uh the
foyet generator I was talking about and
that's just where you you know you've
got your state there there's a bunch of
other stuff up and down but like
basically you just put the information
in that you're you're
requesting um but you know a good
request is going to kind of weigh how
specific you want to get um because
you're you're basically balancing being
so specific that you run into privacy
laws and being so broad that you run
into the argument that it's going to
take too long to get you the information
or it's it's too it's it's too big of a
request that shouldn't be as much of an
issue with data but it it often is so
you really kind of have to weigh that
based on what you want um you know
you're going to end up um occasionally
running into Hippa which is the health
insurance portability and accountability
act which is a nice warm blanket
particularly for State uh government
officials to wrap all of their data in
and keep it from the public um there
obviously like valid reasons for Hippa
but it gets thrown out for literally
anything that touches healthare um
certainly in local and state agencies
um
so also this is probably like obvious to
the people in this room but just to say
it ask for a CF CSV or other machine
readable format um if you want to like
hear you know if you want if you want to
see me start ranting in a newsroom like
send me a PDF when you have a CSV file
like that happens all the time and it's
it's kind of crazy and it doesn't even
like normally stop us because we can you
know convert it but it's uh it's a
common thing that
happens um when you're requesting
information So eventually if you are
requesting information you are going to
run into somebody like this guy um and
what I mean by that is that the first
person you talk to is often a public
information officer who understands data
less than I do and doesn't really know
what you're looking for um federal
agencies are better obviously they they
handle this all the time state agencies
sometimes think it's like willful
ignorance um that they want somebody
that is a wall between you and the data
that you're trying to get so what you
usually end up doing
um again hopefully you've you've you've
already kind of asked for the
information informally and then you know
I often would send the request and then
just follow it up with a phone call and
be like hey can we get your data guy on
the phone and like just settle this
pretty quickly um and it's probably some
of you in this room that I want to talk
to but um that's that's like a really
important part of it is getting to the
person who knows how the data is
actually stored and kept um I had a case
one time where
um the State Police in West Virginia I
was trying to get uh the concealed
weapons permits for the state I just
wanted to see who had concealed weapons
permits there was no law preventing us
from getting that but the state police
claimed that they could not give us this
information and it wasn't that they
didn't want to give us the information
it was that it was in a system so old
that they did not know how to extract
it so and it was literally this was like
10 years ago but it was like from the
80s that they were had all of this on
and I went round and round with them
another reporter got involved we
eventually had to call like the
governor's press secretary and get her
involved and essentially what we had to
do was get from them the software and
Hardware they were using and then we
took that and we put it on a list serve
um of journalists at investigative
reporters and editors called the nikar
list serve and somebody on there you
know explain what was going on was
immediately outraged and wrote exactly
what we needed to do to get the dat
from that system which we then took back
to the state police and said here's how
to do your job and they did it so that
and that actually never even resulted in
a story in the end but like we we got
the data at any rate um that happens not
infrequently where you're like fight for
data and then like well there wasn't the
story there that I thought was
um so after filing your request um you
want to keep track of the de deadlines
um for the agency to respond to you 20
working days for federal that's around
the time for for every for other
agencies um and then this is one that's
really important is memorialize all of
your Communications with agencies about
your request um I often like if I have
what I would consider a bad actor um an
agency that I think is just like trying
to avoid giving me anything um I will I
I have just refus to even get on the
phone with them I want everything in
writing I want everything in email um
because I I know that I might end up in
a legal battle with them and I want to
make sure that I have everything
memorialized so keep that in mind as you
kind of write these and if they call you
I would immediately when the call is
over um write out an email send it back
to them say hey this is what we talked
about on the phone this is what was said
if you disagree let me know but this is
what I my recollection from the
conversation
oh and also um keep your keep your
correspondence Al together don't lose
track of it um put it in a separate
folder either physical or digital so
that you know where everything is
um now when the answer is no the first
thing you want to do is
appeal um appealing allows you it
preserves your right to sue so you don't
have to like worry about well you you
you can sue them later if you decide to
um um you also kind of what you want to
study the response look and see if there
is a
privacy exemption generally they require
you to show your work or to show how
you're releasing information and how in
um how the the information would shed
light um on the government and that's
sort of like the onus is on you to to to
prove that and then you also have
foreseeable harm which is sort of on the
government to determine why releasing
this information
may be harmful to the public individuals
whoever um and then also you know it's
it's not hard to find a lawyer that will
like pay attention to a to a good foyer
request um there's a lot of the freedom
of uh excuse me the reporters committee
for freedom of the press is good with
Federal foyers um and then the V
Virginia Coalition for open government
is great in Virginia to at least help
you work out like what exemptions
they're citing and what what they might
mean
um and generally every state has some
organization like that and a thing to
keep in mind is that lawyers can recoup
fees from these so it's not the hardest
thing in the world to get a lawyer to
take one of these cases because if they
win then they can recoup fees from the
government and you don't end up paying
anything um so then this is my final
slide window to Super information um you
know you're again lawyers can recoup
fees so getting them to talk about it
and getting say your Newsroom which may
or may not have a whole lot of resources
to to get to a lawyer isn't always as
hard as you would think um I know people
think local news and and journalism is
not in the greatest place and in some
ways it's not but also like it's not
that hard to find to to kind of pursue
some of these things even even today um
you know if an agent so so when to sue
is really kind of like weighing a couple
of factors um and I've been involved in
like I've had three of my requests end
up in a Boya suit and been involved in a
couple of others through through
Bloomberg um and it's really kind of
weighing weighing a couple of things is
the agency you know routinely not
responding to information if that starts
happening I start looking for a really
good foyer request that I think we can
win on to sue them because at some point
you end up just sort of in a place with
some of these agencies where
they're just not um they're just not
responsive to Foya they make the
calculation that a lot of foas get filed
and then nobody follows up on them and
often when you show them that yes in
fact I will follow up on this and track
it down then that changes the equation
for them um also it can just speed up
the process um particularly with Federal
foyes like there there are agencies
we're suing one agency now that has a
backlog of foyes because
of coid and were a ton of foas filed
during coid but they haven't increased
their Foya staff and they keep making
the argument that we just have so many
foyers we can't do anything it's going
to take you know two years and we want
the information and we know if we Sue
then that will put it in a different
track um and then obviously look at the
exemptions that are cited and whether or
not they apply um a lot of times
agencies will try to shoehorn a an
exemption um and make it applicable to a
case where it just simply doesn't happen
um the the or it doesn't doesn't fit so
the story that I have up there is one
where actually I sued for information
got the information and then five years
later wrote the story um about that
information so basically I wanted to
find out um what the uh what basically
where where police officers were moving
in Virginia I just wanted to see offic
their movement like you know they're in
one Department they're in another
department when did they move why did
they move and I found out you know
there's a training database where they
kind of have to track all that because
they track you know who's trained what
officers have what training in what
department so I work with the uh the
state agency that had this data actually
got them to we agreed to like kind of a
special we signed a contract with them
basically saying we wouldn't use this
information unless we had it from
another source but to use it as sort of
a
guidepost um we signed it and then the
agency started talking to local police
departments who did not want us to get
to to have that information refused to
give it to us and we took them to court
and won and a couple years later I
finally got a story out of it actually
after requesting the information again
because the first time they gave it to
me it was so they didn't give me like a
unique identifying field um which was a
lesson of my own on doing these always
ask for Unique
identifier so um that's pretty much my
talk um
thank you all and uh I'll be around with
you if you have any Bo
questions